why don't we go next to kank from
arkansas am i pronouncing that correctly
it's kank
oh yes yes you are definitely well
welcome
welcome i'm a big fan of yours i've been
a big fan of yours for like 20 years
it's amazing i'm even talking to you i'm
kind of overwhelmed thank you well
you're doing great so far
okay thank you so much um
i'm a progressive in arkansas which you
know arkansas is super maga super
conservative but that has nothing to do
with my question but basically do you
think you'll ever get a spot in any of
the mainstream news organizations like
cnn msnbc etc
oh i don't i mean i'm not even looking
for that i don't know probably not i
don't i don't think so i can't imagine
they'd be interested in me but i i like
working for myself and setting my own
schedule and taking vacation when i want
and not having you know 12 bosses and
editors and stuff like that so i'm i'm
not even looking for that
well what if there was like do you
remember current tv with keith olbermann
and tyt and yes
if there's ever a progressive station
like in the mainstream in the united
states would you ever consider having a
slot like keeping your business the way
it is you know david pakman channel but
also having your own
hour 30 minute long tv show on some sort
of mainstream network sure i mean listen
i consider all proposals
so certainly if someone brings me a
proposal i would consider it
all right great because i would love to
see you on tv i think you're a great
influence to the american political
sphere and i wish you the best of luck
in
everything you have going in the future
and i wish to see you debate ben shapiro
or stephen crowder or any of those
stupid right-wingers eventually in the
future well thank you and remember we
are on satellite tv every night on
directv and dish network on free speech
tv
yeah i i watch you on free speech tv
very much oh nice thank you yeah but
thank you for taking my call i really
appreciate it all right thank you
there's kank from arkansas very very
powerful declaration
about television